hey guys i'm ryan right hey guys i'm
sally Lomonaco we're gonna watch the
trailer for this movie called hardcore I
really don't know anything about it I'm
totally theorizing based off what I've
read in comments they put together like
a trailer or something so they're trying
to get funds from a Nikko go to do it
but it started sharlto copley or coke
leak and I don't pronounce it anyway
yeah he's a fantastic actor and people
love him in like pretty much anything he
does except for old boy and really like
him in that but anyway he is a fantastic
actor and so everyone's saying like
check this out and see if we can get
more support for this movie so ya must
look good let's uh let's check this out
hardcore hardcore is actually one of my
favorite categories hmm on certain
websites you know we got our four HD -
favorite favorites I have a list of
favorites - on those websites oh okay
yeah hopefully it's about that
it is on beauties and children comes to
quibble on the soul Oh
whoa [ __ ]
that is really hear them but you can't
ship them in for even 800 when they go
they let it how clever
Wow
dudes we play in a real life video
ah
so cool the beaters Wow
I know right
I love it it's like a video why would
it's done that Wow what the [ __ ] how do
they direct this
damn
oh my god I got a Kirby money - this
would be a fantastic thing watching the
themes I'm surprised no one thought
the fact that it's like really vile it
makes it stage really well actually nice
how many
oh yes yes oh my god I am so paying why
I that there's gonna be a dis a link to
contribute in the description box holy
[ __ ] I had no idea was first person
point of view I've seen like one video
on Vimeo that was like a minute long
like that and I remember thinking that's
so amazing like they should do full
movie so the fact that someone's done it
or is trying to do it like yeah and it's
like the action looks like even if you
didn't see in the first person's point
of view it looks like it would still
look cool oh yeah oh it's stylish still
cuz it's not like I kind of run me of
the race yeah everything's happening but
and they put it in it in a way that you
feel like you're that character though
yeah exactly
the closer I got to the laptop the more
I felt like I was really in the moment
of it and like the violence is pretty
cool to look at it it's like because
it's all like in one shot they bring
stuff to life that you did that they
never really did with other movies that
made it look so real like when the guy
gets kicked in these shoots and I'm like
it looks like we could really do that in
real life guys like oh my god that was
great and then I love the way sharlto
copley doing this performance cuz it's
like it is like a video game lead
character very clever very clever oh
[ __ ] I totally got to contribute money
to that hardcore dad this thing is
definitely gonna give me there's no way
and then if they make a video game it's
just like you're the movie yeah even
cooler that's awesome hardcore tells you
it's a good category guys really good
category make sure it's just an HD well
you know you got to keep up with the
technology today yeah mm-hmm don't want
so much at fuzzy-looking video no anyway
guys ever knew the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects sally has
a channel too you can subscribe to her
channel check out all her fun stuff on
there and just make sure to support this
movie hardcore on indiegogo.com support
a hardcore supported hardcore I'm saying
tribute contribute like 70% of your hand
to this movie more than you would tithe
to a church exactly
I don't I said Church I don't either I
keep 100 percent of all the money I make
I make so much money
shabbu saleh he sounds uh
he sounds pakistanian way to go Pakistan
yeah I have a friend from there he's
night Oh
so all pakistani uns must be next hey
Ryan bro
I've been subscribed to your channel
raclette Ohio now and this thang really
do cuz whenever I'm just in a bad mood
or I'm feeling super down on my luck or
whatever or maybe I'm just simply bored
i watch your vids every day and it
always boost me back to my good side so
thank you and your all your whole team
on that channel thank you I can just
imagine him being a bad please leave
give me back my goods ooh yeah I'm
really happy to make you happy you know
honestly the one thing this channel is
missing is me touching myself so you
guys can touch yourself along with me so
if you really want to feel better and if
we haven't uploaded a video in a while
just touch yourself to me and it'll make
you feel a lot better I don't give that
consent back okay
okay well you know sometimes the only
way to editors from the back Oh
Miraflores hey Ryan it would be great if
you gave me a shout out I'm 12 years old
good I'm glad you're watching the video
I love your videos things Ramiro Flores
I believe that I help people your age
advance in maturity much quicker you
know if you're looking for a role model
I think I'm your guy Romero it's all
about going out there and figuring out
ways to manipulate girls into getting
into their pants yeah until you fall in
love like you behind to immaturity I
don't think so every man wants to obtain
a lot of poonanny before they settle you
just boom oh I'm sorry I thought you
were into that and I get wet guys not to
turn you on I just thought it was a
complimentary kind of tribal thing that
we had going on like a friendship spit
that's enhan oh yeah
but for you Ramiro see when you fall in
love you can't talk to girls the same
way you got to make sure that if
something sounds wrong you got to be
like whoa whoa let me let me clear this
up because you know your baby ends up
watching the video and then and then
they get this kids 12 years older I've
never man I give an advice
Jimmy boland hey fellas it's me Nabal oh
I gotta give this guy [ __ ] shout-out
he's the guy who is YouTube named nail
abyss he said we're one of his top 5
favorite youtubers he's the one who
actually traded the new real rejects
logo hi oh good job forever I didn't
saying I want a logo I never tweeted
about this or something but forever I've
been saying like to the other rejects I
want a logo that says the real rejects
it's a film reel that looks like it's on
fire
and we had like a mock-up of it that we
just used as a logo from MSP yeah but he
like [ __ ] did it man and it looks
great so thank you so much Randy this
video honest sincere note for you my
friend
much much appreciation but thank you
Jimmy
and if you know like I said earlier to
the other guy
shabbu if you if you masturbate to me
tonight make sure that you're not
imagining sucking my penis but imagine
me sucking yours
do you deserve it